alright so I'm doing this 140 with a
heavy heart and truly I feel awful
almost nauseous about this and for the
last two hours I've been trying to
figure out what I was going to say right
now I want to talk about this bill cosby
situation let me just preface this by
saying that bill cosby truly is my
comedy hero when I was seven years old
in 1983 I saw his special himself on HBO
and I was sitting in front of the
television in the den in my parents
house my house as a seven-year-old kid
and I remember buckled over painful that
laughter that deep laughter in your
stomach that is painful that you cannot
control and cannot stop and I remember
at that moment being seven years old
thinking I want to make people laugh and
then that became something that I hope
I've done once in a while over all these
years uh and it's led me to all the
things that I do so Bill Cosby truly
truly a hero mine somebody that I've
tried to pin down for an interview a
gajillion times and it just hasn't
worked out uh The Cosby Show I think
it's so much cultural good in America to
show a black family a black upper middle
class family with great family values
and I think in a lot of ways you could
argue that that actually ended up
helping normalize a lot of race
relations to end up leading to our
ability to have a black president not
that many years later 20 20 something
years later uh anyway so yes these rape
allegations are out and uh you know that
the meme thing that you guys probably
saw on Twitter was a really bad move by
his social media people he's now not
addressing it so he's just not talking
about it he was interviewed on NPR
refused to even acknowledge it just went
silent I I don't know what to feel about
this this is someone who I admire and
love and look up to and worshipped as a
comedy icon in so many comics so many
huge comics think you know that he's
really the gold standard Jerry Seinfeld
often talks about how Bill Cosby made
him everything that he is and I don't
know so I don't even know exactly what I
want to say here other than you know
there's that yes you can do something
incredible on earth and also potentially
do some really awful stuff and I guess
everybody has that ability in them I
hope none of this stuff is true that's
really what I hope here that somehow
this isn't true I don't know how this
gets cleaned up and you know the media
of course takes down people before the
trial ever happens and maybe the court
of opinion is more important than
anything else but it's just it's just
sad and I don't know that I can add
anything else